this morning we are remembering a movie
director who changed the landscape of
american popular culture
richard donner's many credits include
the 1978 superman with christopher reeve
we remember that one lethal weapon
and its sequels and the goonies remember
the goonies
all of which helped set the template for
the modern popcorn movie
well we're sad to tell you that he died
yesterday he was 91 years old
and director steven spielberg said this
he was all
kid all heart all the time nikki bates
joins us now to talk about donner's
legacy
nikki good morning i love what stephen
just said all kid all heart all the time
that's a nice way to be remembered
yes by all accounts he was a lovely
lovely man good morning
donner's films hold a special place in
cinematic history and have generated
more than
a billion dollars at the box office
critics say he'll be celebrated for his
ability to create
memorable moments across so many
different genres
i've got you richard donner will be
remembered as the father of the modern
day superhero movie
redefining the genre with his 1978
blockbuster
superman listen to something i have to
do
i'll see you later but it was his range
of work over a six-decade career that
cemented his legacy
i've done some really wonderful films in
my life donner started in television
with credits on gilligan's island and
the twilight zone
i thought i saw something out there he
established himself as a film director
with the horror movie
the omen in 1976 and went on to make
classics like the goonies
and the lethal weapon series raj meet
your new partner
the story has grown it's kept going
which 12 years with this family
he was great at action pieces he was
great with stunts and
elaborate pieces but it was really all
about
human beings it was the characters that
you remember donner and his wife later
founded a company that produced hits
like free willy
deadpool and the x-men franchise
many who worked with him closely said it
was his kindness and generosity
that they will miss most he leaves a
legacy of kind of personal connection
when you would see him in a room
people gravitated toward him
professionally and personally
i think people in hollywood are going to
feel this gap
donner's cause of death has not been
disclosed he and his wife were animal
advocates rescuing dozens of dogs over
the years and fighting against the
captivity of killer whales
donner never had his own children but
was known for helping
actors he worked with paying for rehab
for one gooney star and covering
college tuition for another what a man
what a guy such a class app yeah
wonderful i love when they describe
you that you walk into a room people
just gravitate toward you that's really
nice 91 but it remembered as all kid
and he made superman before the era of
cgi think about that
pretty impressive thank you